what's up i'm kelly clarkson and this is
you do you on the kelly clarkson show
[Music]
this is what's gonna happen y'all i'm
gonna be giving a debatable topic and
i'm going to give you my very correct
opinion on it that's right
[Applause]
absolutely any texan that says no to
that you're kicked out
forever
[Music]
isn't it lacroix oh if you're fancier
i say lacroix i don't know i don't i
don't even drink that so i just have
heard people say it
i don't even know if i've ever had a
lacroix law now i want one
so
no i'm out it just seems like a lot of
movement and it kind of seems like
someone's tricking me into working out
[Music]
who the hell thinks a hot dog is a
sandwich
a hot dog it's like open on top i don't
know the open face sandwich i get i
don't know it's not i'm not into it
[Music]
hawaiian pizza all night long i like it
people that's sweet and salty what's not
to love
[Music]
no and my six-year-old is already asking
me for one and i'm like
you're crazy and you're not ever getting
one until you can pay for one
good luck
absolutely not i'm actually the person
that does me i need to but i like to
leave my house without looking in a
mirror like i don't even
i'm like well just whatever's happening
and then
sometimes i'm like oh how long is that
pepper from breakfast been there i don't
know
yeah i don't know i'm called mom a lot i
mean i guess i don't mind it i'm a mom
it'd be weird if i wasn't but
i'll be your mom
i like whistling i'm cool with whistling
or hum actually you know what though i'm
probably the person that annoys you
because my sister can't stand when my
mom and i we hum
she hates it which is kind of why i do
it
i'm not against it i don't own a pair
but i'm not against it like you
you do you be you if you feel good in
them and you feel like it's a good
statement
by all means
i'm a haha girl i feel like lol is a guy
thing
but i say haha and usually it's not just
a haha it's like
i really want you to know i'm laughing
so it's like extra
shocking but i don't use lol i feel like
lol is like a
a junior high thing you know like
passing notes
i mean if you do it that's cool maybe
you won't do it anymore to me
goodbye
[Music]